julie un nom d'emprunt rêvait d'un
automne tranquille avec ses enfants elle
venait tout juste d'emménager ici pour
repartir à neuf après des années de
violences conjugales l'a toujours été
violent et puis la naissance de mon ami
moi j'ai fait plusieurs maisons de
femmes
à ce moment le puits moment donné je
suis revenu avec l'humain fait des
promesses mais dans la réalité il y
avait pas arrêté de la consommation puis
le c'est là que fait une tentative de
meurtre sur mon unique la première fois
la plus violente
ça a été j'ai voulu me suis bien sûr
métrage avec mon bateau et blanc ses
démarches
ces deux femmes ne se connaissent pas
mais un partage la même histoire la même
souffrance deux conjoints alcoolique
devenu violent lors d'une première
grossesse des plaintes répétées des
accusations pour agressions menaces de
mort tentative de meurtre mais des piges
et donne tout de même une chance à ces
deux paires au passé criminel violences
conjugales et menaces de mort par jour
en cours la dpj le crois toujours plus
lui que moi moi je nai landes
mais ma fille pendant tant d'années à
l'été dans mes bras assise fait plus
elle ne veut pas être enviés ma main je
les ai avisé club ce qui est arrivé avec
le parent puisqu'ils m'ont répondu c'est
le père ça fait longtemps de saut le
pape pourrait être un bon soutien pour
toi
donc si tu veux garder des enfants
on voudrait clubs parviennent dans la
vie des enfants et est ce que la
violence a recommencé la violence à
recommencer c'est sûr on en aura
d'autres l'avocate défendit dizaines de
femmes victimes de violence qui se bat
contre la dpj pour garder ou retrouver
leur enfant j'en ai vu tellement de mer
qui ont appelé la dpj justement pour
obtenir de l'aide des mères
monoparentales qui ont subi de la
violence conjugale et qui se retrouvent
à perdre la garde de leur enfant et
qu'on confie les enfants à ce père la
violence ou à ce père qui a été même
incarcéré alors c'est à n'y rien
comprendre
dans les cas de violence conjugale c'est
après la séparation que les risques d'
homicides sont les plus élevés plusieurs
intervenantes nous ont dit que la dpj
n'accorde pas d'importance à ce danger
ou rien dès que la création est terminée
il ya plus de violence conjugale rapport
aux remarques contraire lorsque la
séparation arrive c'est le moment le
congelé par le pouvoir sur sa conjointe
donc celle qui devient de plus en plus
innovative dans ses stratégies de
contrôle d'ambar la femme
enfin il va prendre la dpj pour elle
c'est en prendre à l avant de travailler
auprès de femmes victimes de violences
conjugales
sophie bolduc était intervenante à la
dpj
elle explique comment on peut en arriver
a confié la garde d'enfants à un père
violent
plutôt qu'à une mère un choc post
traumatique on voit cette maman la quête
action soit bac est parfaitement en
contrôle qu'on connaît pas cette
problématique là on va se tourner plus
rapidement ap ap ap un papa jeu là un
homme violent cc des personnes qui sont
extrêmement manipulatrice des personnes
qui savent s'exprimer et des hommes
charismatiques et qui savent un peu
savent comment jouer avec les walis ce
thème on reproche souvent une femme qui
sort d'une relation violente de dénigrer
le père de transférer ses peurs à ses
enfants
moyens voulu me tuer à ses pieds d'avoir
belle communication avec quelques voulu
tuer celle faisant elle va se faire
accuser d'aliénation parentale que
pourrait elle a vécu l'alliance
conjugale elle peut pas concevoir que
ses enfants sont en contact avec ce pas
par là l effet de les protéger et dans
les codes d'aliénation parentale des
témoignages des enfants peuvent être
ignorées eu plusieurs reprises que ma
fille à le nommer qu'il y avait de la
violence entre la part belle conjointe
de rien de ce qui est écrit en
considération pour sa brosse ma fille
que cela vire t elle là bas qui n'en
vaut pas avez vous vu monsieur
parlez-vous qui va dire oui
par moments à ce choix déchirants l'aaa
d'être obligés d'aller là-bas par an le
plus neuf
le parent le plus neutre pour la dpj
c'est celui qui ne parle pas contre
l'autre ou la personne bilingue ne pas
laisser sa violence envers un aussi
extrême que ça puisse paraître d'un
extérieur
damien c'est le parent qui assène
violences conjugales qui de ville par le
plus apte à offrir un milieu à l'enfant
qui notre équipe et renée d'année et
damman et qu'aujourd'hui je vois ma
fille deux heures par semaine de
randonnée la garde au père qui est
certain en prison je me sens comme si ce
père moi qui avait battu monsieur ces
mères vivent leur expérience avec la dpj
comme une autre agression
elle espère que les drames des dernières
années font servir d'électrochoc que le
gouvernement va en fait entendre leur
détresse
faut vraiment revoir cette loi en
profondeur le ministre responsable de la
dpj promet de réformer l'institution qui
selon lui accorde trop d'importance au
rôle du père dans les années 80 c'était
très important le
l'esp et d'attachement la présence du
père mais je crois que les choses ont
évolué beaucoup et on est prêt à revoir
ses principes dans la loi
moi je me situais boulot j'ai dénoncé
malgré ma part malgré l'homme qui m'a
toujours dit pendant neuf heures ces
supports et des vals de 20,12 ça coûte
trop cher
vous le verrez vous définissez un
journal
si la dpj veut donner la garde de mes
enfants cette annonce est extrêmement
dangereux chouette jusque là des
pigistes réveil qui regarde la vérité
puis regarde la dangerosité de ce tome
l'eau vraiment qu'ils arrêtent de
prendre des risques aussi grave que sur
l'option parle de vies d'enfants
[Musique]